welcome everybody it's been a little
while oh man my graphics are all messed
up see if I can fix him here
oh wow where are my graphics let's see
there they are
okay very very good okay for a second
there I thought we were gonna have to go
without that would have been horrible
today Donald Trump is going to be
speaking at a distribution center for
Owens and minor incorporated they
distribute medical elements essentially
and he flew there and has already landed
presumably he's touring now somebody
just came up and sanitized the
microphone pictures are being taken and
we are going to get a load of propaganda
very very soon welcome to everybody
joining me it's so great to see you it's
been a day or two since the last stream
but it is good to be back thinking about
doing something over the weekend Barack
Obama is going to be giving sort of like
a national commencement address because
of all of the graduating college
students who aren't going to have
graduations and it's going to be
Saturday evening I was thinking maybe I
would stream that I think it's gonna be
widely of it's not gonna be like a1
Network sort of thing so it might be
something better than hearing Trump's
drivel for a change so we'll see about
that
just before heading to Pennsylvania
Donald Trump did speak a little bit at
the White House let's just take a little
bit of a listen to it okay and clearly
you guys can't hear that so let me fix
it there is this weird setting which
sometimes happens on my there we go okay
let's see I think now we got it great
response in terms of doctors writing
letters and people calling on D hi
and this guy's fighting it no reason to
fight it
there's no reason so Trump's talking
about Rick bright who's testifying right
now portly than that we've had
tremendous response to guy drop see it's
not true here here's the deal with
hydroxy and you guys all know I've been
on hydroxy long before Trump was even
around it and I would actually call it
chloroquine it is conceivable that if
it's given to people far earlier it
might have some notable effect all of
the proper peer-reviewed studies that
are RCTs and that have a placebo group
they're really not showing much of an
advantage i I wish that they did and I'm
up for the idea that given earlier
chloroquine may may be effective but we
just don't we don't have really evidence
of that right now and we'll see but I'll
tell you what to me I watch this guy for
a little while this morning to me
nothing more than a really disgruntled
unhappy person and I'm not just talking
about Alex because Alex said it
struggling but there are a lot of people
that do not like the job he did I don't
know I never met him I don't want to
meet him and I watched him and he looks
like an angry disgruntled employee who
notice that anyone who has any gripe
with anything Trump ever did is a
disgruntled employee in frumps mind
according to some people didn't do a
very good job all right any other
question
okay so this is a Republican Senator
Richard burr who's involved in that
insider stock dump in February after
learning about the incoming pandemic he
has he's under investigation a warrant
was served and he stepped down from the
Senate Intelligence Committee Trump for
a moment seems to think that Senator
burr just like stepped down from the
Senate understand at this point Trump
thinks that burr is stepping down as a
senator but then I think it's corrected
with anybody that's what see that is
that the guy appears to have done
insider trading not that he's stepping
down
we got a lot of things going with China
we're not happy about China I will tell
you that the ink wasn't dry on a great
trade deal and all but did I even do
that dry like I can't it's the it's
almost like a Flemmi
thing at the top of your voice I can't
really do that the plague comes in from
China we're not happy about it
I'm okay with it I'm okay with it the W
treat if you look at the world trade not
only the world help and we'll be making
announcement on the World Health
Organization shortly soon probably next
week sometime but the World Trade
Organization is horrible we've been
treated very badly I'm saying it for a
long time and we act on it when I talk
we act on it the world trade they treat
China as the developing nation if
noticed that he keeps talking about
world trade but that it that has nothing
to do with what we're dealing with right
now what China gets a lot of the
benefits that the US doesn't get they
have other countries in a developing
nations and the people sitting in the
Oval Office should never have let that
happen I'm going to Pennsylvania yes
I don't know how they're counting I
never discussed it with them death is
death we don't want people dying in this
country and we've done a great job we've
done a great job I'll tell you what and
death you know the thing about this is
Trump has such a lack of empathy over
the coronavirus deaths but then he'll go
to crazy where he'll say we don't want
death in this country and it's like know
what the issue isn't death the issue is
unnecessary deaths as a result of your
political failures and you can tell like
so when Trump reads off death numbers in
that monotonous totally on empathetic
voice it seems like he doesn't really
connect with the tragedy and then when
he says we don't want any death in this
country it he doesn't get the idea of
the the issue is unnecessary deaths from
this because of your missteps what we've
done on ventilators and what we've done
on testing except the press says it
write it that way
because you have all this fake news
right what we've done in testing we've
now tested more than the entire world
put together right now of course what
matters is per-capita entire world put
together we have many more tests than
they do and better test and the reason
we have more cases is because we have
more testing that's not true we've done
a great job and the people of the river
were 40th in testing now women that have
done this great job should be
acknowledged by the press
[Applause]
yeah I can't hear a word you say I like
how he affords because you get here
anybody that's just--that's is the best
and there goes Trump and Alex days are
and Kaylee Mack and a nanny off the
Pennsylvania where we are now standing
by for Donald Trump speaking momentarily
we'll keep I guess we'll keep the audio
up for when this starts and you've got
people dancing and you've got a lot a
lot of action happening here as you can
see our friend and the with the purple
hair putting together a show here and
some of the co-workers entertained by it
others seem distraught and then some
appear just not to be paying any
attention to what's happening here at
their workplace so it's gonna be a real
party today somebody trying to wave this
individual off as you saw a hand in
front of the camera there and
everybody's masked up which i think is
really really good okay welcome if
you're just joining me we are expecting
Donald Trump 20 minutes ago at
Pennsylvania medical element distributor
Owens and minor Owens and minor is the
name of the company let's get to some
super chats I would love to hear from
you it would give me nothing no greater
pleasure than to hear from you up people
Oh people asking for an update on the
urban garden
I just I'm wearing a t-shirt because I
just came in from a number of
transplants I have finished
transplanting my garden we are past the
frost date here in Boston and
everything's planted there are regular
updates on my Instagram page David
Pakman if you're interested in seeing
that and what else I've had another
small update now I forget what it is I
don't know I forgot here come a number
of people as you can see oh boy a whole
group of masked suits you love to see
that obviously nothing nothing more
exciting than that remember that you can
sign up on my website at join pakman.com
universally known as the best way to
support the stream everybody will get
thank-yous momentarily thank you - lets
see okay Ryan Gallagher says via super
if Trump is defeated in November he will
actually defeated I can think of at
least two other people who now have a
path to the White House who were worse
than him Don jr. is one imagine that
nightmare
okay Ryan I don't fully know exactly
your question but we've got a defeat
Trump is the message let me put it that
way
Zachary Monroe's by the way really weird
things happening here
Zachary Monroe says hey David thank you
for your hard work covering The Annoying
Orange we have a for president loved the
show keep up the great work
like and subscribe yes always remember
like and subscribe on YouTube follow on
Twitch we are 5 twitch followers 5 not
50 not 500 5 followers from 35,000 which
would be a delightful delightful round
number people on twitch saying they saw
my pickles yeah I showed everybody my
cukes yesterday on instagram my cucumber
plants and most people had some
complaint I planted them too close
together the soil looked dry it wasn't
clear that there was fertilizer it
wasn't clear that there was compost
listen guys these are my cukes and I
make no excuses for them on my Instagram
page thank you to Warwick B da for the
twitch Prime subscription liquid ice
says hi David thanks for the work you do
I just graduated from an IT bachelor's
degree program first class to not have
an opportunity to walk in a ceremony
also from Wisconsin our Supreme Court is
dumb ok very good
Jimmy tenpins has reached his
subscription and says thanks for a great
show keep up the excellent work thank
you and nzn 8 has subscribed with prime
as well thank you so much twitch does
make it easy to connect your Amazon
Prime account and support us at no cost
to you I believe it's twitch on
amazon.com where all of those things are
happening back over on YouTube super
chats continue Ken asks thoughts on the
removal of Santos the defense production
head I really don't know enough about it
yet to be able to say much Pere tearin'
says what should president in orange say
about all kind
boycott all America in and out travelers
I think what you're referring to is the
possibility that I'm gonna I'm gonna
Paris Swedish so I interpret for what
pair is asking about is what would Trump
say about other countries continuing to
ban Americans from coming in American
flights and I don't know what he would
say he would probably attack them and
blame the news but that is very likely
to happen as other countries are
improving and we really are not
fargo-moorhead whose fall United says
David why do you think he has these
talks in front of the helicopter so he
can yell did past presidents do this
regularly I don't remember anybody
yelling in front of the helicopter as
much as Trump Daniel Rivera says free
speech Republicans now oppose mail-in
voting yeah there's a lot of hypocrisy
to go around that's just one element of
it my state Minnesota is lifting stay at
home order may 18 do you think it's
careless to reopen right now I think
that there are states that are ready to
start doing some things I here in
Massachusetts were scheduled up until
now the stay at home is only until the
18th I'm expecting some little
expansions of what is allowed by Monday
but I don't know enough about the
situation in Minnesota too safe to say
for sure a retro path acts as if you
love these pray if you like these press
conferences you'll love WWE jr. says all
the wrong people coming together at the
right time to create this four-year
misuse of power and somehow ability to
get away with it over and over vote it
cannot be stressed enough well said well
said Sophie Faraday says what's the
future for universities I mean listen I
I think by the spring universities will
mostly be back and these could be famous
last words we will see thank you to
Queen goddess of awesomeness for
subscribing on twitch gun busted has
subscribed
Slingblade has subscribed for five
months in a row also thanks to cheer
oshi for the support and titan mars
productions we are in the midst of a
vigorous hype train right now over on
twitter
as we stand by for Donald Trump if you
are watching on YouTube
remember that hitting that like button
and the subscribe button is just
unbelievably helpful to us pair tieran
asks Wow David you might have green
fingers I hope your girlfriend doesn't
turn into Groot they just I don't have
no idea what that means the discussion
can be limited love the show take care
of yourself and your coworkers
alright Don Horvath says dr. arrange
this is mad I am sorry USA okay Ryan
Gallagher says sorry didn't proofread my
question is if Trump is defeated in
November will he stay defeated well I
mean listen there's no doubt that maybe
Don jr. or Ivanka are going to try to
run for president at some point in the
future but Trump will be defeated in
November if he is defeated and that will
be that for the time being thanks to
Keith Wickersham for the super chat
Patrick Miller says what are ways that
we can reach the middle III you that's a
complex topic and and I would check out
my interview with Rachel Vinick offer
from last week highly highly recommend
that interview let me say thank you to
Theresa Swain who is new member number
one today at join pakman.com and David
Chaudhary David his new member number
two today at join pakman.com so
appreciated of course the best way to
support all of the work we do many weeks
we are doing 20 or more hours of content
between the streams podcasts audio video
etc the best way is just grab a
membership on my website it pulls
together all of these different
platforms it's our primary source of
funding and it's it's direct from you to
me there's no middlemen there's no this
company or that company taking bigger
and bigger slices of your contributions
and there is a coupon code 2020 now
which will save you 66% as some of you
know in March and April we we bore the
brunt of 722 membership cancellations
which was by far the worst two month
period we've ever had we know why 20% of
the country is unemployed and I I
totally get it
so the if you've cancelled we're still
here for you the show continues to be
free it's all available it's for
everybody if you are in a position where
a buck or two a month is something you
could contribute through a membership or
patreon please do and the coupon code
2020 now drops memberships to just two
bucks a month and I will Thank You
profusely I mean really-really pro few
Slee everybody who signs up gets I sing
their praises to the extent that I'm
able
Sakura Foster says Mac Ana nanny brought
in to trump's fourth wife and you're
noticing sexual attention there Samuel
Lopez says when I started this that we'd
seat though that's funny that's what my
mom calls me unknown prodigy says my
mommy and I are becoming closer thanks
to you a lot of mom talk today gamer Rex
what were that go gamer exes did you see
the Wisconsin bar packed 45 minutes
after the stay-at-home order was
overridden no I did not let's take a
look briefly at that Wisconsin bar 45
minutes after the bar opened no masks
and it is very very busy yeah I mean
there Wisconsin is is it's very possible
that Wisconsin is going to be in real
trouble
Texas is having Trump's like
everything's getting better everything's
getting better Texas had sixteen hundred
new cases yesterday they had their most
new cases yesterday in Texas and they're
not even testing that much it's really
really ugly what's going on there okay
at which people to thank a user named GW
Jumpman bdb has subscribed get Trump out
twenty twenty has gifted a subscription
twitch strike mostly ends and
as-seen-on-tv
have all subscribed on Twitch which I
love I just love it Patrick Miller says
when can we call into your show we
usually take calls Wednesdays at 12:15
p.m. Eastern Time and then they they are
published on YouTube over the weekend
I'll give you a preview of the calls
there's some good calls actually this
weekend let me pull them up I have a
list of the
all's we took yesterday okay oh there's
a one that the title is actually there's
a typo okay fixed it so somebody called
in about masks like who should be
wearing masks and when should there be
masks everywhere all the time I gave my
take on that I got called out for my
take on populism versus social democracy
and argued with a caller about that I
was attacked by another caller for my
claim that the u.s. coronavirus response
was one of the worst in the world I took
a call about whether there's an internet
socialism pipeline we know about the
alt-right pipeline the question was
about the socialism pipeline and I got a
call about what would happen to health
insurance company employees under
single-payer there's some good calls
there's certainly some very very good
calls this weekend that I look forward
to you guys checking out let me thank a
few other people Leslie Martin has
signed up at join pakman.com and his new
member number three thank you so much I
really appreciate it I again see people
asking about is my hair long enough for
a ponytail and will I have a ponytail
listen my hair is long enough for a
ponytail I have a fistful as you can see
and I could definitely put a device I
don't even know what they're called I
could put something on it a rubber band
but I am NOT going to do it right now
and as I've said before we've had a
little trouble hitting that membership
goal lately if we hit the membership
goal next stream I I will put my hair
into a man bun if that's what people
want but it is ready now it we would be
able to do that right now okay Keith
wickersham says hey David great show
what do you think the odds are of
Democrats winning the Senate
specifically in North Carolina well
North Carolina is one thing I you know
we could look at the polls there and
it's not looking great for Thom Tillis
I actually think that a year ago I would
have said there's like a five you know
three percent chance Democrats win the
Senate six months ago I would have said
it's like a 15 percent chance now I
would say that it is about a 40 percent
chance that Democrats take the Senate
that's my completely unscientific
assessment Nate silver might say no the
chance is only 22 percent
uh-uh that's just you know where I'm at
right now
those aren't facts that's my feeling I'm
being clear about it that's my feeling
Wolfpack says any answer you want go
watch a past Pakman video go we'll go
watch a past video Pakman I don't know
what that's about Steven K says trump is
one County over from me I feel violated
Sam Dean says what if Sam say is it
worth watching Dave 4:40 a.m. yes of
course it is hope you do in well mate
thanks for what you do Sam you're always
up so late in Australia I would be
curious whether you work all night or
what how you're always up solely
traversée media says big fan thank you
for being a voice of reason I see a lot
of delusion on both the left and right
lately the level-headed content is
appreciated if you like the more
philosophical policy-based
segments on the show we have like a
15-minute segment coming up later today
it's already been ripped it's in the can
as we say about the concept of is it
evil to vote for the lesser of two evils
we get into content philosophy we get
into the trolley problem and all sorts
of different elements I think people are
going to like it that's coming out later
today I want to say thank you on twitch
to look daddy
as well as live Christ acts or Clive
Chris Texas which I very much appreciate
and as far as website members I want to
say thank you to Tyrone weights the
weights
who is new member number four today at
join pakman.com remember that the
program and these streams are mostly
buoyed by website memberships at join
pakman.com and one of the great things
about the website membership is you get
the bonus show on Monday I showed people
prepping components that I've acquired
recently as many of you know I've become
a completely mild left-wing prepper
thanks to coronavirus and on Monday
I presented a lot of these prepping
components to the audience and had
further questions as I only minimally
understand how some of them are used so
if you sign up on my website I recommend
go right to the Monday bonus show it's a
very very good one okay Robert Mifflin
says did you see Mike Moore documentary
on cons of green energy no I have not I
want to see it I've just been so busy I
hear a lot of people are very very upset
with it but I have not I have not seen
it yet skunk games says Trump's intro
music for today's rally it's the end of
the world as we know it by REM he can't
play Guns and Roses twice in a row Axl
Rose was lighting up Steve minuchin on
Twitter I loved it
Jake Feldman says facts are on life
support so thanks for the oxygen pretty
but complicit and dishonest new press
secretary is pronounced pronounced
Kaylie McEnaney yeah I know I know but I
think I'm just gonna continue people in
the audience were yelling at me when I
pronounced that McKenna knee they said
it's mcenany when I said mcenany they
said it's McKenna knee so now I'm just
adding a syllable Mac Eynon a knee is
the pronunciation for today and we'll
we'll keep adding a syllable Jackson
says would you be willing to moderate a
debate between Steven Steven Kenneth
destiny bonel the second and Kyle
kolinsky let me say unequivocally and
with no hesitation whatsoever that I
would absolutely moderate such a debate
and if anybody wants to set that up I
would want it to be on my it can be on
everybody's channels but it would I
would want it live on my channel as well
obviously for the traffic I would gladly
moderate such a debate golfer Jack says
in Missouri I'm about to open my store
in a mall on Monday no talk of masks
whoa no talk of masks or new guidelines
only to print out a sign that says stay
six feet apart that doesn't sound great
that doesn't sound great Andrew Starr
says do you deny Obama used government
agencies against a political rival all
his intelligence officials went under
oath said there was no evidence of
wrongdoing so you're using language
that's very loaded you the same question
could be asked as
were were intelligence agencies
investigating actions by the Trump
campaign and associates while Obama was
the head of government and the answer is
yes your framing is a different one for
which I don't yet see evidence waffles
jirafa says Democrats need to target the
dumb it's the biggest voter group check
out my clip on YouTube it's time to
admit that a lot of people are stupid
check that out I think you will enjoy it
heavily very very heavily let me say
thank you to Joan pano who is new member
number five today at join pakman.com I
will continue to thank folks who sign up
at join pakman.com remember that it is
really really cheap and it is really
really fast and we get ninety seven
point one percent of every membership
payment if you make a twitch
subscription if you send a super chat if
you pledge on patreon I'm not allowed to
tell you the size of the slice that they
take but what I can tell you is it's
more than 2.9 percent which is what we
pay to swipe credit cards on our website
and thus it is the most recommended way
to support the streams and it's not
expensive my friends it is not expensive
the coupon code above my head twenty
twenty now chops two thirds off of the
price of a membership don't feel
obligated by no means don't feel
obligated but twenty twenty now does
save you sixty six percent which is
beautiful it's a beautiful thing okay
Zappa GOG says no question just want to
show some appreciation for your awesome
work with a small donation thank you
Chris K says mountain of PPE there send
that to hospitals yeah I'm guessing this
is all PPE that is about to go out pair
T Ron says please give the international
telephone number call in order to Tonto
or prays you make the mods to write it
since I have hard of hearing oh boy
paired the phone we only have one phone
number and the phone number is six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
you
call it that's the number no matter
where you are now if you don't want to
make a long-distance phone call you can
use Skype if you're in Sweden or
elsewhere where it's just I think it's
like pennies to call the United States
phone number via Skype from Sweden I
think oh that's right these boxes may be
empty as mr. Hasselhoff is pointing out
Mike Pence got caught the other day
moving empty boxes that didn't really
have any PPE in them so these boxes may
just be completely empty babsi Khan says
have you considered doing a
collaboration with Ring of Fire one day
for your show yep Farren is a good
friend of mine and so actually well it's
a different story but this t-shirt I'm
wearing is related to bring a fire in a
way I was just texting with Ferren
yesterday and I've done I've appeared on
their show I've done stuff but I don't
know exactly the type of collaboration
that would make sense now both of our
channels independently are doing well
and we have a pretty big audience
crossover I'm always up for doing
something somebody has a suggestion
doctor orange is pronounced doctor
orange regarding Lysol talk says Don
Horvath okay
JP Dunphy says keep up the kick-ass work
DP Townsend coke says thoughts on
extrapolating Christie's lost the larger
progressive versus establishment dem
debate specifically as it relates to
Medicare for all no I don't think that
we can take the California twenty-fifth
results and deduce anything about 2020
november 2020 because remember there was
a Democrat who had to resign I mean
listen I don't really call it in shame
in the sense that I don't care that she
had a relationship with a staffer but it
was a resignation in shame in the sense
that they violated House Ethics
guidelines so there could be a backlash
effect there where people are voting for
the Republican because the Democrat got
bad publicity and leaving that also
historically has been a Republican
district so I'm not reading very much
into that at all it may be a sign of
November of what's gonna happen in
November I just don't think there's
evidence of that yet desiree has signed
up on youtube I appreciate that
Nathaniel Haney says don't know if you
were joking but don't use a rubber band
for the bun
it'll hurt so bad taking it out good
luck yeah sure what should I use like a
velvet scrunchie or something I don't
even know that's a joke by the way other
super chats coming in David Mello says
pandemic recession and now a trolley
problem too
I know things are crazy Joel Oh Joseph
says feel sorry for you in the States
greetings from Sweden and thank you for
a great show
Carmen Edward says hello David first
time here well welcome I appreciate your
support I want to say thank you to
Valerie Dixon who is new member number
six today at joined pakman.com also want
to say thanks to Christopher Lenox who
is new member number seven today and
Roger Rivera hey Roger good to see you
Roger is new member number eight today
at join pakman.com eight out of 25 not a
bad start not a bad start also thanks to
AJ Wilcox and Justin winters and Goku
Goku I see what you did there for the
subscriptions over on Twitch we are only
close to an hour behind when Donald
Trump was supposed to speak so that
suggests to me he'll probably be coming
out pretty soon Keith Jacobs says have
you seen the Epoch Times YouTube ad
blaming the pandemic on China I have not
I have not Mattias Germany says would
you like Hillary and a Biden
administration
I don't need Hillary in the but listen
there are so many people who would be
good candidates for a Biden
administration
I wouldn't go crazy if Hillary had a
role and I wouldn't go crazy if she
didn't it's not a big deal I think just
reducing scandal and returning to
normality or normalcy would be the
priority
Andrew Starr says the FBI cleared Flynn
and the next day Obama held a meeting in
which he discussed details of a
political rivals private call all right
Andrew thank you zesty African says how
do you think it's possible that Trump is
literally Orange do you think he uses
fake tanner
I think about it from the standpoint of
water please well let's see oh and we
have no audio here I don't know why
let's get over to the White House stream
that might help us we've been having
trouble with the Fox News streams lately
I'm guessing this is going to start any
second I don't know why the tab is not
muted so I'm guessing that we are going
to get this stream going soon the White
House stream let me mute that briefly
and then we're gonna be over here and we
don't want the music because of
copyright issues we'll wait for Trump to
come up standing in front of boxes of
gowns music still going a little bit of
if he is orange he's particularly orange
today looks like he's rienner and you
see the reverse raccoon eyes that are
going on and we are very very close to
the start of this so this is actually
looking more like a rally than have been
a coronavirus statement quite frankly
[Music]
that's pretty impressive but we like it
the way the little bit better don't we
and we'll be back we'll be back to that
soon I think I really believe it and we
were received by thousands and thousands
of people coming in and they came in
from all over and all the way down the
airport to here was everything Spectre
sit down let's have a little fun and
we'll talk and then we'll talk about the
business of the great job that you're
doing and we really appreciate you being
here thank you very much
I'm honored if it's true thousands of
people were crammed together welcoming
him then that's going to be a hot spot
in ten days passed away a long time ago
Fred and he went to Lehigh University
I've been up here many times actually
and I gave a commencement address years
ago at Lehigh University great school
but whenever I think of this area I
think about my brother but I really am
honored to be with the extraordinary
work
of Allentown Pennsylvania every day you
prove that American workers are truly
the best in the world and that's what
they are we're showing that now we're
starting to make more and more product
in the United States I was with some of
your representatives associates they
call themselves I don't know I assume if
they're Associates you're all making the
same money I hope so
they call themselves associate sounds
nice right more and more I see that but
it's good and they're good and they're
doing a great job frankly but they're
talking about so much of the product now
is made in the USA words in the past it
wasn't it wasn't but they were talking
about ninety percent eighty to ninety
percent it's made of what you distribute
is now made in the USA and that's taking
a long while for us together that
started that right for the understand
that big picture there's been no
dramatic shift in the percentage of
domestic versus foreign goods here just
the big picture you know it may be true
as it applies to this one Factory but
that's generally a meaningless statement
groundbreaking initiative to replenish
and modernize our strategic national
stockpile the cupboards were bare you've
heard me say it a lot now that's of
course not true I have an interview
today actually with Andrew Lake off
about that stockpile and I think you'll
find it very compelling should hub
because the workers here at Owens and
miner have a critical role in this
national effort and it's a critical role
that you've fulfilled incredibly well or
it wouldn't be here I would have found
someplace else and thank you for those
beautiful hats I appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
from the moment this terrible virus
reached our shores each of you has
worked relentlessly to get the vital
supplies to our health care warriors and
they are warriors aren't they when you
see them going into those hospitals and
they're putting the stuff that you
deliver but there are a pin themselves
and the doors are opening and they're
going through the doors and they're not
even ready to go through those the doors
bro we shoot you but they can't get
there fast enough and they're running
into death just like soldiers run into
bullets in a true sense I see that with
the doctors and the nurses and so many
of the people that go into those
hospitals it's incredible
it's a beautiful thing to see but I
really call them warriors we're all
warriors everyone in our country is a
warrior we have to be because of what
happened and it should have never
happened
should have been stopped at the source
but each of you has work relentlessly to
get those supplies to our health care
warriors and all across the hospitals
and specifically for this plant in New
York New Jersey and Pennsylvania as you
know the pandemic is inflicted profound
hardship especially in the areas that
you serve sounds like it really means
within one heartbeat America grieves for
every life and every family all of those
that have been lost and all over the
world
186 as of this morning hundred and
eighty six countries what a horrible
shame shame and we thank God for the
courage of those on the front lines and
you make it possible for them just as
the men and women of Allentown have done
in every generation I know it well the
workers at this facility of answered the
call in America's hour of need many of
you are working long before dawn get up
and you go to work and long after
midnight I know your hours I was talking
to your people and your representatives
they say she wouldn't even if I'm saying
what are the hours they said you won't
even believe it I said but I worked
those hours to work we're all working
hard you're driving forklifts staging
pallets packing picking loading and
shipping all sorts of things all over
these primarily three states since
February you have deployed an amazing
1.75 million n95 respirators and you
make them now yourselves 3.4 million
gowns 80 million gloves and much more
and on behalf of our nation I want to
thank you he has you making America
proud
we really do we thank you very much
thank you all I'm grateful to Owens and
miner president Edward petechiae along
with you chief operating officer Jeff
Jacobs Giacobbe we're also joined by
secretary Alex a czar doing a terrific
job and your statement to the press
today was fantastic he made a very
impassioned strong powerful statement
today hey stars for FEMA administrator
Pete Gaynor Pete thank you very much
great job fantastic job you're dealing
directly and you and Admiral John Paul
of check was yet Admiral great job thank
you very much are they doing a good job
here Admiral oh good
why are they all traveling around was a
trump at a time like this it's crazy and
the CEO of the u.s. International
Development Finance Corporation Adam
Barr Thank You Adam fantastic
every incredible worker here today is
part of the greatest mobilization of
American society
since World War two you know that we've
done things with generators and
ventilators and so many different things
we're making products and nobody ever
thought would ever need in any mess form
ventilators is the biggest thing we made
plenty of magenta lighters which was
very little in the country because most
hospitals didn't need very many and you
know what's so weird about this like
this is the way he usually talks during
the White House press briefings but like
talking about ventilators in this tone
they're just a roomful of workers it's
particularly weird the Admiral and with
all of these people and Jared some where
Jared is here what they did is
incredible we brought geniuses in from
Silicon Valley and all of a sudden
within a short period of time we had 11
plants out making ventilators cheerio
and you wouldn't believe what it is and
now we're we have so many every state
has more than they need we filled up our
stockpile we have over 10,000 now
and we filled it up we're ready to go in
case anything happened we now have over
10,000 two months ago then are we
already supposedly at 13,000 that's
weird is with ventilators cuz nobody can
make you know you can't make them
they're very tough to make very
expensive them I say it's tougher than
making a car and we make the best
ventilator - so that's completely untrue
making a car is far more complex than
making a ventilator ventilator is
actually relatively simple over the past
few months the federal government is
partnered with with Owens and minor and
other distributors to launch the very
successful and historic project air
bridge which is really being thought of
and spoken of in glowing terms nearly
150 flights have brought 95 million
masks 16 million gowns and nine hundred
and twenty 1 million gloves to America
can you believe that nine hundred and
twenty-one million loves it's not even
conceivable now do you think when he
says nine hundred twenty-one million
gloves is that individual gloves or
pairs of gloves
I actually am cured that is nuts not an
attack on Trump I just don't know truly
remarkable accomplishment after meeting
the immediate demand will be
transforming and transitioning from
project air bridge to Sealift where
we're using big ships giant ships that's
less expensive and they can carry a lot
more and we don't need to speed any more
because we're very stocked element now
as our country begins a safe and gradual
reopening we're launching a monumental
effort to replenish and rebuild the
strategic national stockpile we also did
that by the way with fuel when oil went
down we replenished our strategic
national reserve and we got it for a
great price would you believe what went
on with fuel but now it's starting to go
back and we're saving our energy
industry because people didn't need too
much gasoline when there were no cars on
the road and I said to the governor's I
said you know there are no cars on the
road this is a good time to fix your
highways fix your highways now some did
great insight and some
didn't write they didn't they were
worried that two people working 35 feet
away from each other or driving a
tractor or whatever they might be doing
they'll catch the virus it's really
interesting I regularly see tractors
used to repave highways tractors no
traffic and I can tell you Florida was
the state great governor and Ron was was
he told me he said I'm doing it I said
that's a good thing not everybody did it
run DeSantis the floor governor of
Florida but some did and save tremendous
amounts of money in rush hour they're
building and they hardly had a close
Elaine so you know there are a lot of
good things you can do but some some
people decided not to do that under the
method being in previous administration
the stockpile was depleted and never
fully refilled most of the n95 masks
were distributed during the n1 h1 now
you know who says that right n1h one who
says said sleepy Joe Biden here we go
so Trump actually said it wrong he said
the n1h one I said this is it the other
way around they said yes sir Trump just
said it wrong and to cover he says that
that's how Joe Biden says it but Trump
said it wrong one and one and that's the
swine flu and it was a pandemic in oh
nine that was not well handled right got
very poor marks yeah check out the never
again will another president inherit
empty shelves or expired products at
least hopefully in five years you're
talking about actually it's very likely
if Biden wins in November he will
inherit a lot of that stuff thanks to
Trump but you'll never have to deal with
empty shelves and you'll never have to
deal with the depleted military the
military that we took over was depleted
and in horrible shape widely the
announcement 1.5 trillion dollars
rebuilding even Jim mattis has confirmed
that this is a lie and we've ever had by
far and there's a good time to have it
too and all of the product was built in
the USA but I'm determined that
America will be fully prepared for any
of the future outbreaks of which we hope
this going to be none who would have
thought 1917 it could have been up to a
hundred million people were killed
remember who could have thought he had a
pandemic response team he cancelled it
he had a pandemic response playbook he
ignored it happened that's over a
hundred years ago our effort begins by
dramatically increasing our reserves
instead of one to three weeks worth of
supplies which we had less than that the
US government will now stockpile three
whole months much of it made in the USA
my administration has already awarded
contracts for approximately two hundred
thousand ventilators which we're
building ourselves and now that now
genuine question three days ago they had
orders for a hundred thousand
ventilators now he says it's two hundred
thousand did they do another hundred
thousand in the last 48 hours is this a
lie was that a lie does he just make up
the numbers these are the types of
questions we just don't know hundred
thousand now it's two hundred thousand
well we didn't never hear about a second
order I don't know desks and they're
making face masks they're making a lot
of different things that three months
ago they never even thought about
they've geared up it's incredible what
some of the companies have been able to
do you've seen that what Honeywell has
done an incredible job they've done but
many of them are manufactured by Owens
and mine are many of the things that
we're doing and and delivering happily
to places that were not able to get it
done by Owens and minor thanks to a
major investment in Del Rio Texas your
company plans to produce an astounding
20 million n95 masks per month that's
more than you do here I don't know
you're gonna take that I don't think so
that won't last long
right I think in that 20 million in 95
minutes per month and that's gonna be
very shortly next my administration is
taking action to modernize the
stockpiles during this crisis
Admiral full of Jack and his team built
a cutting-edge system that allows the
federal government to integrate
seamlessly with our nation's largest
distributors to procure produce and
deliver astonishing quantities of
supplies where they're needed the most
we have an incredible system hope we're
not gonna need it but it's there right
way it's there it's there like nobody
would even believe and the press doesn't
ever talk about they don't want to talk
about there they are right there they
don't want to talk about it they are a
disaster but that's okay the people
understand and that's all that really
matters when you get right down to it
guys going forward we'll build on the
system to create a stockpile that is not
only the best resource in the world but
also evolves to meet all of the new
threats it can happen things that you're
not even thinking about right now
hopefully this guy's gone in seven
months and he doesn't have to be in
charge of any abortive stockpile
nonsense and we can get adults back in
charge Tate are vastly expanded
inventory the final step in rebuilding
the stockpile is to bring critical
manufactured permanently back to America
wouldn't that be nice right we're doing
it and we've been doing it my goal is to
produce everything America needs for
ourselves and then export to the world
that that includes medicines it's very
important to reliant on other countries
and I've been saying that for a long
time long before I became elected
president right he knows he's been
hearing it to this end earlier today I
signed an executive order just signed it
and broken the defense production Act to
grant new authority to the US
International Development Finance
Corporation just a little while on the
plane this federal agency normally
invests in economic development projects
in other countries I said how about
investing in our country we invest in
other countries global as you noted
globalists is they want yeah man I don't
know what I think it's just propaganda
what everybody to do well
we have to take care of America first
it's gotta be America first and you know
what other countries say the country
first why wouldn't they do that but we
didn't do that we had a bunch of
globalists they didn't know what they're
doing so America first is bad enough but
now starting to use the term globalists
these are very very well-known dog
whistles that have both anti-semitic and
xenophobic undertones and they're cow
toeing it's red meat for a very
particular part of the American right
Trump may not even know it right but
these things have gotten to be part of
his lexicon and we were never even close
to that
the best unemployment numbers we've ever
had african-american asian-american
Hispanic American had the best job
numbers in history in the history of our
country they never did so well
best income numbers best stock market
numbers 401 k numbers the good part is
the stock markets because they know we
know what we're doing the stock market's
ready to to move never went down like a
lot of people say wow it's twenty three
twenty four thousand it was twenty nine
thousand it never went down like people
would have assumed because they know
what's happening they know smart people
a lot of smart people they know what's
gonna happen
it's just manipulate amazing next year
one of our best but we had the greatest
year ever and then we had it turn it off
artificially induced we're to turn it
off and if we didn't do that we would
have lost two million people instead of
whether it's ninety five thousand a
hundred thousand one is too many
so I've already debunked the two million
thing a bunch of times so I won't do it
again now it's just exhausting to do it
every time even it was a little less
multiply what we have by twenty or by
fifteen wouldn't be acceptable wouldn't
be sustainable people would have said
what's going on over you multiply as bad
as you've seen it and you know you can
say what you want about the flu but I've
never lost anybody to the flu that I
knew I mean I've had people friends they
have the flu and the sick they don't
feel good
and you call up how you're doing you
know three days two days a week later
they're fine nobody ever said they died
but I've lost five people that I know
Trump doesn't know anyone who got a good
friends of mine okay
and you call up two days later how are
they doing sir they're in a coma
I said they're in a coma sir now they
were old I wouldn't say they were the
greatest of Health I wouldn't say they
await was perfect not perfect but they
God so this is just terrible terrible
yeah that's a good point
didn't Trump's grandfather die in the
1918 flu I just forgot that Trump
doesn't know anyone who died who didn't
his own grandfather died of the flu this
afternoon I also have great news on
testing you know we've been doing
testing at a level that nobody's ever
done it before we cannot get any and we
cannot get the press to write about it
or write fairly about nobody has ever
done we've done double what anyone else
if you add up all of the countries in
the world we've done more testing than
all of the countries in the world added
up together nobody's ever done anything
like that and we have the best tests we
have tested two months ago didn't even
exist or great companies came up with
things Abbott Laboratories and so many
others they came up with things that
Roche they came up with things that
nobody even believes so we have the best
testing in the world it could be the
testings frankly overrated
maybe it is overrated but whatever they
start yelling we want more we want more
you know they always say we want more we
want more because they don't want to
give you credit then we do more and they
say we want more but we have the
greatest testing in the world but what
we want is we want to get rid of this
thing that's what we want we want to get
rid of this thing okay so afternoon I
also have great news on that testing
America is now conducted its 10
millionth test that's as of yesterday
afternoon
10 million tests we gave 10 million and
CBS has just committed to establish up
to 1,000 new coronavirus testing sites
by the end of the
month and the ten-millionth will go up
very very rapidly and don't forget we
have more cases than anybody in the
world we now but why because we do more
testing that's not my test you have a
case when you remember we're 40th in
testing Oh with people if we didn't do
any testing we would have very few cases
right that was his strategy at the
beginning don't do testing to avoid
cases it's common sense so we test much
more many many times South Korea here
about I spoke with the president of
South Korea spoke with many different
presidents prime ministers here we go
they can't believe what we've been able
to do on testing they can't believe what
we've been able to do in ventilators
recently the Manta leaders other
countries Italy Spain other countries
France is having tremendous problems
France is actually doing way better than
with ventilators they can't believe the
job we're doing and it's not me it's
it's the people all of these people but
it's the people that are doing it and
they have to be given the proper credit
for what they've done because what they
did is a miracle no other country in the
world has done what we've done and they
feel very free now to call us because
they need help especially with the
ventilator because it's hard that's not
a cotton swab that's a very hard thing
very very hard thing tip it is joining
us today are a few of the workers who
have kept our hospitals supplied through
this crisis and take part in a great
great rebuilding that's going forward I
say it's the transition to greatness the
transition is the third quarter the
fourth quarter is going to do very well
and next year is going to be through the
roof we have hopefully with another
personal thing you just saw it opening
up a little bit you have areas of
Pennsylvania that are barely affected
and they have they want to keep them
closed can't do that Dennis DeCarlo is a
Marine Corps veteran who served our
country in the Gulf War and Somalia now
he continues that spirit of services and
operations supervisor and Dennis please
come up and say a few words code no
they're doing full
propaganda now I'm honestly what's the
relevance of a soldier to this I don't
even understand I I want to first start
by saying thank you to all my teammates
out there we've we've had a lot of Bo he
worked like tears and I I want to say
thank you to you guys you guys are
wanted oh my god is training I know
we're in a crisis situation with our
country and you know people have asked
me how it's changed for us it's it's
almost with little modifications it's
it's day-to-day business for us
as dealing with the medical supplies but
I feel the one emphasis is on the
seriousness and whenever you're dealing
with the medical field it's a serious
thing but there's it's exponentially
grown with what we're dealing with now
and if we make a mistake its amplified
so
[Applause]
okay that was weird this is all weird I
don't know if anybody else agrees good
man give my hand come on offspring I
could see they like you done they were
told to be very low-key when you walked
up they said we don't care we're
clapping for Dennis thank you I saw what
went on there
Eric Yost is a distribution teammate who
is now in his 26th year with Owens and
miner and he says he has never been
prouder of you work right here in
Allentown we love Allentown I love
Allentown Eric please come up short okay
sorry about that yes I want to thank
he's also if it wouldn't be for this
great team of Owens and miners all over
the nation's we wouldn't be here today I
want to thank you all thank you again
the 26 years that I've been here
we started off kind of small back when
steward was transitioning over to owns a
miners to bank a long story short we
started with little stickers and modern
technology today revolved to where we
have our refs
and we're better to equip Hospital it's
a lot quicker and pick it perceive it
real fast and then when disc rotavirus
came into place we had to really react
and we did a great job on that I mean
think about all them numbers that the
president threw out there I mean that's
the phenomenal job we brought it into
this buildings we got it in we got it
out we got this is the Hawks entire meat
of all this the hell is my hat
definitely goes off to all you guys
thank you very very much
[Applause]
thank you very much
Carol Tim is a safety and training
coordinator who has taken on extra
duties during the emergency Carol please
come up Thank You Carol and I think
everybody knows I've been so excited
about your visit oh my god
I'm the safety training coordinator and
my job is to make sure everybody goes
home at the end of the day which is very
important to everyone's family it's
important to America because it's
important for these people to show up
the next day because these are the
unsung heroes that save lives every day
and they do it humbly
mr. president I wish you could have been
here when we get the order to start
transporting the mask and the gowns and
everything that needs to go out to these
hospitals when that order came in
teammates from all different shifts just
stopped without hesitation and they
float like magic in this facility
it was amazing to be able to see that
and they did
[Applause]
and you mentioned about the notice the
look on Trump's face it's like they're
praising him even when there is just a
factory that's right it's a distribution
center and they're moving product which
is great but Trump's look is as if
though he is being thanked for this
stuff and they are thanking him for a
lot of stuff which is weird but the boy
everything he thinks is just an
adjudication of his great job we're
really blessed in this st. was some
tremendous congressman who really worked
hard but a really incredible teammates
sean Parnell it's gonna be fantastic to
hope that all works out but he's gonna
be he's an outstanding person but they
really work very hard and I could say
that some don't and some do the state
you have a lot of hard workers so you're
very well represented but I want to
thank you all because four generations
American greatness was made forged and
won in places like Bethlehem and Easton
it's a home of Larry Holmes right Larry
Holmes she's still in Easton oh good
we'll say hello he was some fighter huh
he used to talk about Easton that's
great
say a little Larry in Allentown your
ancestors in this region are the
Patriots who mind the call loaded the
rail cars and board the steel that built
our biggest cities and raised our
tallest towers I built some of them it
says the places where it starts in the
20th century Pennsylvania workers helped
put America on top of the world now
we're reclaiming our heritage as a
nation of manufacturers you saw how good
those numbers were going up up up I'm
gonna have an interruption but you watch
what happens starting in the fourth
quarter probably starting in the third
quarter a little bit the transition
quarter but you'll be we're gonna be
bigger and better than ever I've learned
a lot we've also learned not to rely on
others so much let's do it ourselves
let's build it ourselves
yeah governors have learned not to rely
on the federal government in these cases
when the government is run by Trump but
once again you're gonna lead the way
with your help we will vanquish
the virus we're gonna vanquish the
plague I got the plague because that's
what it is we'll get our nation back to
work and we will build our glorious
future with American hands and American
grit and American pride you have heart
I want to thank you to everyone at Owens
and miner I want to thank you for this
great area of the world as I told you I
think of Fred Fred my brother Fred god
bless you and God bless america thank
you very much we're gonna cut that very
low-energy sort of weird thing I mean it
was like a propaganda rally type thing
but it was low energy and it didn't make
any sense and Trump lied constantly and
I mean it's just everything about it was
so bizarre and weird very very odd let
me thank some people we have continued
to see the bar get filled up here with
with members I want to make sure
everybody gets to thank you Tracy loop
Akos signed up Tomoko McGahee as well as
Robert hatch John Shannon Marian Renton
Ruth van Wisniewski Valerie Dixon
Christopher Lennox and I think I already
thanked Roger Rivera very much
appreciate that
a few super chats that came in
interesting that they're allowed to wear
a mask alongside the president at least
they're taking it seriously
yeah they weren't gonna come out and say
pull the masks off today Valentin says
hey David big fan here used to think you
calling these propaganda was a bit of
hyperbole but damn you're right
nationalistic overtones and all Matt
Chavez says why isn't Trump wearing a
mask there's PPE behind him yeah he's
not gonna wear the mask Trump said he
thinks he'd look ridiculous it would
make it into campaign commercials
against him and that it would be bad BAE
photo says ten million tests a day would
be better of course Patrick e says David
great show thank you how about comparing
South Korea's current unemployment rate
to the current US rate I know nothing of
that I'm here I want to look at that and
Richard K says reprehensible photo-op
Trump has stacks of surgical gowns
behind him and not in the hands of
health care workers those boxes may have
been empty for all we know Eamonn
Barrett says hey David loved the show in
your presentation style balanced and
assertively critical just bought one of
your groovy gulp guzzling mugs being
from Ireland we are saddened by what's
happening in the United States Matt
Chavez asked what is the purpose of this
I was asking myself the same question
BAE photo also says that's Warhol's
brillo boxes of gowns behind him
yes extensive extensive propaganda here
James said the area Trump is in is a hot
spot in Pennsylvania I live very close
to that warehouse there were probably a
couple hundred people gathered not this
thing's distancing not surprising not
surprising at all all right guys thank
you for joining me today appreciate the
support we will be back when there are
more events and we will have clips
publishing to YouTube every 90 minutes
for the next eight hours hope you'll
check out some of those remember to
leave a like or a dislike honestly it
doesn't matter both count about the same
in the YouTube system thank you
you